and done Oh different try hello I'm
Hannah Hart and welcome to season two of
edible history the show that explores
the appetites of our ancestors today
we'll be dipping into the history of the
French fry the humble potato you can
mash them you can roast them or you can
cut them into little strips and fry them
up at hot oil so many delicious options
from such a simple spud but have we
always celebrated this tubular tuber to
help me catch up on the history of these
golden rods of deliciousness I'm talking
with the president of the culinary
historians of New York our friend from
season one
Cathy Kaufmann Cathy I'm so happy that
you're back and not only back but here
for our premiere episode of season 2
today we're gonna be talking about
french fries how interesting could that
history possibly be they're potato
sticks when they were first introduced
into Europe really they were thought by
some to be poisonous
I can kind of understand that you take a
potato out of the ground doesn't
necessarily look appealing
so in this great french fry controversy
who makes the first claim I've heard
that they come from Belgium
[Music]
or something that looks pretty much like
a french fry in mid 18th century France
there are rumors that there were fried
potatoes in Belgium and the Netherlands
and also in Spain but it's a question of
the documentation right right
the data started to come popular in
different areas in Europe at different
times the first recipe that we have is
from a cookbook from around 1755 Deluca
which is summers at port so we're
talking about a fairly elite cuisine it
is attributed to aid the co-terminal
he's got a recipe in there that is for
several different root vegetables you
actually the batter that talks about has
wine in it you deep-fry them and then
you serve them either with mustard ice
white sauce you mentioned the recipe
calls for mustard that's one of my
favourite things
what type of mustard would they be
having at this time I don't think
there's any question but that would be
Dijon we were relatively short travel
from Dijon to Paris the mustard makers
have been famous in Dijon for centuries
at this time and it's delicious so what
were they using to deep-fry at this time
that depends on the day of the week at
this point the Catholic Church still has
its fast days and it's fat days
the fat days mean you can have meat the
fast days means you have to eliminate
meat from the diet you've got to keep in
mind that this is a dish that's being
served for wealthy people
so for a fat day you would be frying in
lard
whose fat duck fat that sort of thing on
the lead days I didn't even know you
could fry and clarified butter so when
the recipe we'll be making today is
there a specific way to shape the fries
to cut them french fries because at this
time symmetry and elegance of your knife
work and the way food was actually
presented at the table was Kathy it is
such a pleasure to have you back I'm
just frankly really excited to eat some
french fries so I'll see you later
today's recipe comes from the Year 1755
and from the book Luo super DeLuca ah
was that it and my French now
our first step in making french fries
actually doesn't involve the potatoes at
all it involves the water we're going to
be boiling them in first we're going to
make a little bit of a paste using
butter and flour lip-lock magnifique
dddd dddd and we mush it all together
buttery paste this recipe is off to a
good start now that our butter and flour
are well incorporated we add it to our
water next is the salt now the recipe
doesn't call for a salt at any other
point so we're gonna add a pretty hearty
helping next we're gonna be adding our
potatoes totally whole into our
delicious buttery soup the recipe says
it takes only a quarter of an hour to
cook aka 15 minutes we're gonna turn up
by heat and practise more French
pronunciation alright it looks like
these bad boys are boiled we're gonna
take our potatoes out and set them aside
to cool so we can peel them talk about a
spud muffin now it's time to peel our
potatoes we won't be using the standard
peeling method with the peeler but
instead because they're so warm and
steamy we're actually gonna just use
this towel and kind of slough off the
skin oh there goes Oh
[Music]
does it look satisfying cuz it is
alright that is the last of our petits
now it's time to move on to the slice
so to slice our potatoes we're going to
be making the following series of guns
cut the first down the middle then we're
going to establish how thick our
potatoes are by slicing down the sides
beautiful now as Kathy mentioned the
cooking style at this time was pretty
obsessed with symmetry and balance so
this is our way of making sure that each
of our potato batons are well shaped and
de beautiful so we got our little stack
and a half next and there you have it
our first little set of soon-to-be
French rice Ezrin for improvement
let's fry today might be the best the
kitchen of edible history has ever
smelled this is pure beautiful gorgeous
gold and duck fat I'm salivating as I'm
talking about it it smells so good all
right our next step is to make our wine
batter we're just gonna be using a
little bit of wine and a whole lot of
flour
it wouldn't be French cooking without
the wine give a little bit we're gonna
mix it up a little and then add some
more
[Music]
the next step is to batter our fries
we're only gonna do a smaller portion at
a time these are some fancy fancy french
fries people you have to make each one
with intention that give it a little of
this
we take our well battered fries give
them a gentle shake and then very
delicately okay yeah I feel like we're
really honoring the French fries right
now they have opinions oh my god
the batter is kind of puffing almost
like a fish stick at this point you're
looking for this beautiful golden color
I think if color looks great so we're
gonna take them out we're gonna put them
to the side I'm going to take another
handful and we're gonna fry up the rest
of these it's important to add your
fries in small batches so you don't
change the temperature of your oil
that's something I learned today and
explains why everything I've ever
deep-fried has gone terribly wrong this
was a real spectator sport
emphasis on the tater okay that's the
last little bit of this the smell is so
good can I please try them
have you ever been so excited about
something for so long that you're almost
nervous for that moment to finally come
you feel like I'm taking a bite of
edible history in this moment it is
truly an honor to get to eat you in
honor of our french fries we have a
little French wine and a little French
Dijon mustard this is exceptionally
delightful for me as I am a huge mustard
fan a little partial to wine - okay
french fry give it a try it's oh my god
mmm I'm never gonna be able to go back
this is the way a french fry is supposed
to be I honestly thought that the batter
would detract but honestly
hmm the batter really provides a
structure than a crunch and the french
fry contained within whoo perfectly
cooked I thought the duck fat smelled
good that doesn't compare to how it
tastes and with the Dijon it's a perfect
pairing you're perfect I'm complimenting
you this Trump's the modern French fry
entirely Pete thank you so much for
watching this episode of edible history
come back and make sure you watch the
rest of the season to see if anything
stacks up to how good this french fry
was
[Music]